for the millions who follow British
royalty 2022 will stand out in history
for generations to come the year Queen
Elizabeth II celebrated 70 years on the
throne the Platinum Jubilee I think I
might just put a knife in
it but it was also the year her
extraordinary Reign was to end this was
the last the world saw of her on the 6th
of September appointing her 15th prime
minister at Balmoral Castle in Scotland
she died two days later throughout her
life Her Majesty the queen my beloved
mother
was an inspiration an example to me and
to all my family
and we owe her the most heartfelt dead
any family could owe to their mother
was a state
mentary and tradition Millions reacted
with respect and fondness most of the
British people had never known any other
monarch
the Queen's coronation was in June 1953
in Westminster Abbey she was only 25
when she acceded to the throne more than
a year before
70 years after his mother was crowned
here King Charles will have his
coronation in Westminster Abbey it will
be steeped in centuries-old Tradition
but there'll be a difference in tone an
attempt to save money in difficult times
for the economy of Britain at 74 King
Charles will obviously have a much
shorter Reign than his mother but he
will face major difficulties
isolated incidents like this don't help
but the public standing of King Charles
isn't his main problem and while
grumpiness may not be normal protocol
the reported feedback from this incident
was mainly positive Royal Watchers
saying it shows even a king can have a
temper tantrum
serious issues abound though not least
the role of prince Andrew who stripped
of Royal duties and most of his titles a
woman in the U.S accused him of sexual
assault when she was 17. he's made a
financial settlement with her but he
denies any wrongdoing to describe what
happened with Prince Andrew's
association with Jeffrey Epstein and
Glenn Maxwell as the Scandal is in some
way to understate how horrific that is
before the palace to have continued to
give shelter
and to give credibility is unbelievably
damaging there's a hierarchy of the
family you know there's leaking but
there's also planting of stories Prince
Harry and his wife Meghan Markle present
a potentially even more damaging issue
on the freedom flight the six-part
docu-series on Netflix set out the
couple's Grievances and why they decided
to leave Royal duties and move to the
U.S
we can't disregard the impact of the
Harry and Megan split but I think it's
pretty clear that the monarchy will
weather this as it has so many other
storms
not all Royal Watchers agree with that
optimism though other issues include a
police inquiry into some of Prince
Charles's Charities over allegations
that cash has been donated in return for
Royal honors there is consternation
about the monarchy's future in
particular its 14 overseas realms
I still don't think that we'll see a
republic during his lifetime but I think
the prospect of a republic
has drawn closer and I think a lot of
the overseas Realms will depart during
his reign
there's a big majority in favor of the
monarchy in the UK but critics say King
Charles needs to make the royal family
more relevant to British life and to
crack down on scandals and excessive
spending Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera
London
[Music]